presque tout absolument tout il ya une
énorme différence entre être cantonné à
s'exprimer uniquement sur sa page
facebook ou sur son compte twitter et
quand on parle politique il faut le
faire il faut passer par un proxy faut
parler via des des applications
particulières pour ne pas être espionnés
etc
il faut faire gaffe enfin bref c'était
un cauchemar orwellien
désormais c'est fini on peut s'exprimer
on peut dire tout ce qu'on a envie de
dire sur tous les sujets qui nous
concernent peut critiquer on peut se
moquer on peut descendre en flammes
si on a envie donc absolument tout a
changé
bon accessoirement je suis passé d'un du
statut de journaliste web à celui de
chroniqueur à dieu était radio et télé
ça fait 1 ça fait quand même un bon
changement